觉得这件事情没有对和错之分啊，
就是你要想好，
如果说你真的能做到，
像文菲姐刚刚说的目标很明确，
我去了就是要成长，
我去了就是要见市面，
我去了就是要借助他们家的资源和人脉，
我去了就是要学习经营管理，
我去了就是要让我自己成为一个独立的很能挣钱的女人的话，
能不能嫁，
能我的话是刚能满28岁，
我是碰到了一个情感方面，
思想认知上的一个问题，
然后有点左右亿，
就是我80%的情况下，
我是觉得我是对的，
但是可能也是因为受家庭，
就是父母的一些思想上的一些影响，
就是我的想法是有问题的，
然后对我有一些自我怀疑，
或者说我是不是真的就是父母口中说的那种不好，
就是坏孩子，
就是小少年这里听到一些指导和建议，
好的，
你说说啊，
我们是在听一线城市在小康家庭吧，
我自己的话有四五十个城派，
家里面的话呢，
有三套房子在出租，
自己住一套，
家里还是弟弟父母在做，
是小的生意，
因为我有28岁的嘛，
也是面临车婚很多年了，
我现在目前的话呢，
是有谈一个男朋友，
比我大三岁，
但是你记得有小孩，
就我家里弟弟，
反正他是一个离婚的嘛，
小孩是多大了，
是跟随前妻啊，
还是跟你的男朋友是岁跟前妻。
其实我更多的是看重这个男孩子的家庭条件，
他们家庭阶级的话，
比我们家高好几个台阶，
其实我更多的是希望为自己以后的后代找一个就是说厉害一点的工作，
保障他的一个成长环境和教育条件，
因为我小时候我是如果父母是白手起家，
所以到我小时候的说条件是很苦的，
包括我的父母的话呢，
他们也没有说回到小孩很多的一个教育上的条件，
包括那个时候生活费啊，
各方面都是比同龄人都要差很多，
我就不希望我将来的后代也丰富我这样子的一个成长环境，
我希望比他更好的教育条件和能够让他有更好的选择和未来，
所以我是看到这一点，
然后我自己的话呢，
是没有什么很大的一个物欲的，
但他们家对我其实也很大方的，
送了很多东西，
但是候基本上都没用过什么，
就可能因为跟小时候这个不错的成长环境没有关系，
所以我对物欲没有没有什么期待，
我就是对于自己后代的教育条件啊，
还的成长我比较很看重，
我现在纠结的点是，
我是是应该先父母的选一个普通通的男生头婚的，
然后过这种平凡小日子，
还是说今天我自己的想法，
因为我不管是从农村出来的，
所以他们的思想各方面都是很落后的，
觉得对小孩子到底不需要什么花钱要正好自己完成义务教育就可以的。
这种想法你知道他俩为什么离吗？
就是他跟他前妻为离。
啊，
好像是也是因为金钱上的纠纷吧，
他就是感情不和，
那你知道他爸妈是做什么工作的吗？
就是商业上的，
他们家的这个家底儿流动资金大概是个什么规模，
固定资产大概是个什么规模，
流动资金我没有具体去了解过，
但是估摸这房子比我们家是好像好很多吧，
能说的具体一点吗？
就是说他们家的房子有几套，
值多少钱，
他们家的房子应该是有几千万吧，
然后这个男生他本人是干什么工作的，
工作是在自己在公司上班，
那他的收入呢？
多的话一个月大概四五万，
他跟你谈恋爱这个过程大概多久啊，
快点的，
他在你身上有什么付出吗？
有，
就是精钱上的付出也有，
大概给你花了多少钱，
20个左右吧，
你自己是干什么的呢？
自己也是上班的，
但是我是跟朋友一起创业，
一个月收入大概在1~2万，
那你收入也很好，
非常棒啊，
姑娘啊，
是这样的选择这个东西其实谈不上对，
谈不上错，
我只能告诉你，
如果你选择这样的家庭，
将来你可能面临的风险是什么，
好不好？
所以按照现在的婚姻法的司法解释来说的话，
基本上女性想要通过婚姻去穿越阶级，
想要通过婚姻是拿到财富上的大结果的，
这个路已经被堵得死死的了，
就算你嫁过去了，
房子不是你的车子不。
是你的，
就算房子登记在你名下了，
将来也未必是你的，
因为他要考虑钱是谁出的，
谁对这个房子贡献更大，
这是法律要考虑的问题，
所以呢，
你如果嫁到这样的家庭的话，
你要知道啊，
姑娘啊，
正常情况下的很相爱的人走入婚姻的话，
都有一半的概率是要分手的，
更何况是这种就是重组的家庭，
他前面还有一个妻子，
还有一个孩子，
门不当户不对的家庭，
就是说散伙的概率的话，
摆在这儿，
散伙的时候你能拥有什么呢？
就是如果说你觉得孩子可以借助他们家的家庭能够得到更好的教育的话，
大概率下孩子是归他们的，
不是归你的，
等到真有一天散伙的时候，
那你能拥有什么？
如果说你跟我说龙飞姐，
我这个人啊，
我很会为人处事，
我待人接物，
礼貌各方面，
人情往来各方面，
我都是一把好手，
我如果嫁到这样的家庭的话，
他们家的上下游关系，
他们家的合作伙伴，
他们家的世交，
我都能打点的服服帖帖的，
我都能把他们家的资源幻化成我自己的资源，
我在做生意，
我在做买卖，
就算他们家不给我钱，
我凭借他们家的这些人脉关系的话，
我也能把这个生意干起来。
如果你今天告诉我龙飞姐我是这样的风格的话，
那就去干，
如果不是的话，
那你将来要面临的风险，
可能你确实是为你的孩子图了一个好的前程，
但是你自己没有得到一个好的前程，
大概一想，
嗯嗯，
确实是概率这。
摆着都不要把自己当成是那个特例，
不要把自己当成是那个说怎么怎么样，
跟别人不一样，
我们都一样，
我们都是凡夫俗子，
我们都有爱恨情仇，
我们都有自尊，
我们都有自己的小骄傲，
我们都有自己的性格。
我觉得这件事情没有对和错之分啊，
就是你要想好，
如果说你真的能做到，
像王菲姐刚刚说的，
目标很明确，
我去了就是要成长，
我去了就是要见世面，
我去了就是要借助他们家的资源和人脉，
我去了就是要学习经营管理，
我去就是要让我自己成为一个独立的很能挣钱的女人的话，
能不能嫁，
能有这样的契机，
我把自己提升到那个档次的话，
能不能嫁，
能就对自己一定要认清明白，
如果你要嫁的话，
记住啊，
姐妹啊，
也要那些虚的，
就是要彩礼，
在结婚之前的话，
一定要真金白银打到你卡上的彩礼，
反正就是掏心窝子的讲，
他们家有这个经济条件，
她能看得上你，
他上来啊，
给你什么六十万八十万的彩礼，
比说房子登记在你名字下面要靠谱，
OK,
好啊，
就这样啊，
那谢谢，
嗯，
拜拜，
真的出发解释就是这样，
即便是说房子登记给你了，
但你们结婚时间短，
或者说哎，
没有什么共同的子女，
人家男方也没有什么过错的话，
如果人家男方说，
哎，
结了两年的婚，
觉得没啥意思，
想跟你分开了，
真正到分财产的时候，
还是要考虑这房子是谁买的，
你知道吧，
龙飞。
想多了，
给个10万20万的就是一大关了，
我讲的就是这个意思啊，
就是这个姐妹，
因为他赌的也是他的人生啊，
而且我跟你说有钱人啊，
没有一个傻的，
他也知道咱们图啥，
其实说一千道1万，
还得我们自己能够立的起来，
还得我们自己能够有能量，
在这个社会上有一定的影响力才行。
记得点赞关注哦。